>> Sean: ANDREW CUOMO
REMAINS DEFIANT TODAY AND AT
THIS HOUR CLAIMING HE NEVER
TOUCHED ANYONE INAPPROPRIATELY
AND REFUSED TO RESIGN.
NEVER ACTUALLY DID ANYTHING
WRONG AS GOVERNOR EVER.
BUT ALL SEEMING TO HAVE ZERO
IMPACT ON THE GROWING CALLS
FROM WITHIN HIS OWN DEMOCRATIC
PARTY FOR HIM TO LEAVE.
AND RESIGN.
HERE IS CUOMO EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I NOW UNDERSTAND THAT I
ACTED IN A WAY THAT MADE
PEOPLE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
AND I WANT YOU TO KNOW THIS
FROM ME DIRECTLY.
I NEVER TOUCHED ANYONE
INAPPROPRIATELY.
YOU ARE RIGHT, YOU CAN FIND
HUNDREDS OF PICTURES OF ME
MAKING THE SAME GESTURE WITH
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE.
WOMEN, MEN, CHILDREN,
ET CETERA.
YOU CAN GO FIND HUNDREDS
OF PICTURES OF ME KISSING
PEOPLE.
MEN, WOMEN.
IT’S MY USUAL AND CUSTOMARY
WAY OF GREETING.
I’M NOT GOING TO RESIGN.
I WORK FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF NEW YORK.
THEY ELECTED ME.
>> Sean: DON’T FORGET IT WAS
ANDREW CUOMO, HIMSELF, WHO WAS
THE FIRST TO CALL FOR MANY
OTHERS TO RESIGN IMMEDIATELY
AMID HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS.
ONEE GOVERNMENT WATCHDOG TOLD
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" "NOT SO
LONG AGO, GOVERNOR CUOMO
DEMANDED TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IMMEDIATELY DENY ALLEGATIONS
OR RESIGN."
POWERFUL WORDS.
DOES HE NOW HOLD HIMSELF TO
THE SAME STANDARD?"
AND CUOMO WAS AN I BELIEVER
HIMSELF, AND WANTED BRETT
KAVANAUGH TO TAKE A LIE
DETECTOR TEST.
WILL HE HOLD HIMSELF TO THAT
STANDARD?
WILL HE TAKE A LIE DETECTOR
TEST?
IF THE MEDIA MOB HAD ETHICS OR
STANDARDS, ANDREW CUOMO WOULD
HAVE BEEN UNDER FIRE LONG AGO
FOR WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
NURSING HOME DEATH COVERUP IN
THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE COVERED IT ON THIS
PROGRAM FROM DAY ONE.
BUT FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC, THE MOB, THE MEDIA
WAS RARELY INTERESTED IN ANY
SERIOUS COVERAGE OF CUOMO.
WHILE HE WAS OUT THERE TALKING
AND DO YOU THINK THE POWER
POINTS, TRUMP WAS BUILDING
HOSPITALS, MANNING HOSPITALS,
CONVERTING THEM TO COVID
CAPABILITY, PROVIDING EVERY
VENTILATOR HE DIDN’T BUY
THOUGH IT WAS RECOMMENDED BY
HIS HEALTHCARE TASK FORCE.
PROVIDE EVERY SET OF GLOVE,
GOWN, EVERYTHING.
CUOMO NEVER USED THE HOSPITAL
BED.
NEVER USED THE HOSPITAL SHIP.
TO THE EXTENT HE COULD HAVE.
80% UNOCCUPIED.
BESAW HEADLINES THROUGHOUT THE
BEGIN -- WE SAW HEADLINES
THROUGHOUT THE BEGINNING OF
COVID.
WHY WE ARE CRUSHING ON ANDREW
CUOMO NOW.
A PIECE IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" ENTITLED ANDREW CUOMO
IS THE CONTROL FREAK THAT WE
NEED RIGHT NOW.
SOME REFERRED TO THEMSELVES AS
CUOMOSEXUALS.
WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
THE DEMANDS FOR TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY, SHOULD
HAVE STARTED LAST SPRING.
THE MOB, THE MEDIA, THEY WERE
TOO BUSY SWOONING OVER HIS
POWER POINT PRESS CONFERENCES.
NOW HERE WE ARE ONE YEAR
LATER, GOVERNOR CUOMO IS STILL
REFUSING TO TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE DAMAGE,
THE PAIN THAT HIS EXECUTIVE
EXECUTIVE ACTION CAUSED AND
CLAIMING TODAY HE HAS NEVER
DONE ANYTHING IN THE PUBLIC
CAREER HE IS ASHAMED OF.
ALTHOUGH, THE GOOD NEWS IS
SOME POLITICAL REALITY IS
BEGINNING TO SET IN.
MAJORITY OF THE NEW YORK
VOTERS HAVE HAD IT WITH CUOMO
AND SAY HE SHOULD NOT EVER BE
ELECTED FOR A FOURTH TERM.
MANY WANT HIM GONE NOW.
HIS APPROVAL RATING CRATERED
TO 33 POINTS.
ONE POINT IN THE PANDEMIC AND